hello everybody my name is markiplier
and this is kind of the moment that you
guys have been waiting for I got the
oculus rift and I'm playing a horror
game alone in the rift which is supposed
to be absolutely terrifying so here we
go
tried a few times to get this to work
before it's a little finicky but we have
got it on lock so playing in the sitting
position and we're starting out in this
field okay so I haven't gotten far out
of here and it's still really trippy by
the way to be able to look up and oh
there's my hands this kind of floating
there but I think that's okay okay so
you need to use WASD to move around and
then Q and E to turn now my flashlight I
don't seem to be able to control but
then again this game also can be used
with the razer hydra which is supposed
to be able to let you move those hands
that are floating down there that I
can't see okay I also got that volume
turned like way far up in my headphones
so whatever's gonna come out at me I'm
group oh that was a tree again I keep
getting startled by small things in the
distance sorry not to the scares yet let
me just hold on to my horses okay so I'm
freaking out because I'm turning left
and right I still go on forth just like
totally different experience than any
game that I've ever played before so
let's see here I believe this is made on
the unity and there's my hands again
what is in my hands that a flashlight
that's pointed up at the trees yeah
that's real helpful okay wait a minute
where am i sweet am I supposed to go
into why did it get quiet it got really
quiet all of a sudden why I want to know
why okay okay we're fine it started up
again okay so I see something down there
what is that
more lice set of paths of lights that I
need to follow I've no idea I can't even
tell what that is over there yeah
because this is a Developer Kit of the
oculus rift the resolution is not that
high it's not HD but it's still pretty
good
and enough to create the illusion okay
my eyes adjusting this can I actually
see more is that a thing is that
actually a thing I have no idea okay
all right going up the hill what the
hell okay
people who said that this is like
unbelievably scary so I have what is
that oh it's a house okay so it's a
little shack full of glowy glowy light
what's in the shack
okay that's a little girl isn't it let's
see hi what what hell okay alright okay
I wish that flashlight would point down
where I need it on the ground what's a
bear how do I get a bear
uh can i sprint killers Rhydian please
oh I fell down into the pit I went back
into the valley where am I going how do
I get up there there's a lot of music
going on right now
oh okay
it's something actually all right holy
crap there's still a light over there
you can go over there but you guys okay
you guys gotta understand that this is
very disorienting for me okay all right
I've got a path here and the music is
like kicking it up I got that Orchestra
on my back that just wants to play music
all day long okay I've gone up the hill
because I saw lights up there okay
there's something over there unless this
is the way I came from originally I have
no idea once again it's very easy for me
to get disoriented here so don't blame
me if I go the wrong way this might have
been the way I came from which should be
fine with me because that means uh-oh
it's like it's right there I mean I've
now gone off where's my food mushy okay
oh okay yeah this is where I oh no this
is different is it what is that what is
that what is that what is what what is
that is that just a rockers out of
something
okay that was just a rock okay I'm sorry
that was dumb this is back in the
beginning I thought I saw like a figure
in a figure okay I need to turn around
and go back apparently because I've made
a horrible a yeah stop it do you just do
that random times or how about when I
turn around
sorry about the spit okay let's just get
back down the hill because I think there
was something else there that I needed
to find going the other way so I saw I
don't know I don't know what I saw I'm
getting lost again there's my hands
floating in the air who cares let's go
down there I see a bright light it's
where I'm gonna go just follow the
lights I don't know if they like riff
this music from a movie soundtrack or
something but I don't I don't know
what's going on here
okay let's no don't don't stop suddenly
don't thump suddenly either on the music
okay let's go up the hill Oh fine we'll
be totally what is that what is that
what is that I can't move forward wait I
came back the wouldn't go away he was
like right there and he wouldn't go away
is there not an end to that a real loser
is just supposed to wander until I died
oh my god alright so that was alone in
the rift angles I had to take it off cuz
he was literally just like standing in
front of her she was literally standing
right in front it wouldn't go away I had
to make her go away so anyway that was
alone in the rift holy go Wow it is like
that wasn't even a good horror game
that's not what I would say is a good
horror game in any other game but that
was absolutely terrifying you guys this
is amazing this is amazing you guys have
if you have a tent get your hands on one
of these it's amazing I like it probably
didn't get conveyed on this because
on YouTube in 2d but you guys got to try
this so anyway oculus rift is awesome so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye